man the writing this season is just so
lazy the writers are just completely out
of ideas and investigating Trump the doj
sends a search warrant to Twitter and
Elon Musk personally fights it how is
this even real life I'm gonna let scowl
deal with this one thanks Devin Trump
was permanently suspended from Twitter
two days after the January 6th right his
account was subsequently reinstated
after Elon Musk bought Twitter but Trump
hasn't tweeted since preferring instead
his truth Social account on January 17
2022 Federal prosecutors working for
special counsel Jack Smith applied for
and received a search warrant directing
Twitter to produce data and Records
relating to the at real Donald Trump
account
the warrant sought a ton of information
from Twitter as part of the special
counsel's investigation into January 6th
the warrant was served along with a
non-disclosure order which prohibited
Twitter from notifying anyone about the
existence or contents of the warrant for
180 days
prosecutors shared fears with the court
that if Trump knew about the warrant
that he would jeopardize the
investigation by giving him an
opportunity to destroy evidence change
patterns of behavior or notify
Confederates Twitter didn't take it so
great Twitter challenged the
non-disclosure order saying Twitter had
a First Amendment right to tell Trump
about the warrant because some of the
records may contain materials protected
under executive privilege and then they
refused to turn over the records until
the issue of the non-disclosure order
was resolved well they lost and had to
pay 350 000 in fines for contempt of
court for the trouble to understand how
all this came about we have to start
with the stored Communications act
because the warrant of Twitter was
issued under the auspices of that act
the Fourth Amendment preserves the right
of the people to be secure in their
persons houses papers and effects
against unreasonable searches and
seizures by the government a
governmental seizure of personal
Communications generally requires the
issuance of a warrant based on probable
cause due to an individual's cost
institutionally protected reasonable
expectation of privacy sending emails or
privately messaging someone through a
social media platform however requires
the user to give information to a
company that transfers processes and
holds the user's information the
principle known as the third party
Doctrine generally holds that the Fourth
Amendment does not protect private
information shared with third parties so
you can see the issue if I'm using a
social media platform to send messages
then maybe those messages aren't
protected by the Fourth Amendment maybe
law enforcement can get them with a
simple subpoena to that provider rather
than a search warrant you've been served
have a nice day
I don't like you the stored
Communications Act was passed in 1986 as
Title II of the Electronic
Communications Privacy Act the purpose
of the stored Communications Act was to
strengthen the privacy of Internet users
by adding a layer of statutory
protections over the Fourth Amendment
it's also frankly poorly written and
Incredibly outdated to put that in
perspective 1986 to 2023 is as far as
2023 to 2060. sorry for ruining your day
Millennials but I'm one of you historic
Communications Act is codified in 18 USC
sections 2701 through 2713. now we are
not going to do a deep dive into the
entirety of the stored Communications
act but a couple sections are important
to understand section 2702 prohibits
certain internet service providers from
knowingly divulging customer
Communications and Records to any person
or entity under certain circumstances if
a service provider improperly divulges
customer Communications or records that
customer can sue the service provider
for compensatory and punitive damages
section 2703 identifies how state and
federal governmental entities can compel
providers to disclose electronic
communications and Records now this can
get pretty complicated but a search
warrant is the gold standard that
compels providers to disclose stored
data in virtually every case and the
section goes on to explicitly say that
no provider can be sued for complying
with a facial valid search warrant
finally section 2705 provides the
mechanism for a non-disclosure order a
governmental entity can apply for and
obtain a Judicial order commanding a
provider to whom a warrant is directed
for such period as the court deems
appropriate not to notify any other
person of the existence of the warrant
the court shall enter such an order if
it determines that there is reason to
believe that notification of the
existence of the warrant will result in
any of five enumerated harms those
enumerated harms broadly cover
endangering the life or physical safety
of an individual flight from prosecution
destruction of or tampering with
evidence intimidation of potential
Witnesses or five otherwise seriously
jeopardizing an investigation or unduly
delaying a trial investigations that use
non-disclosure orders are sometimes
called covert investigations for your
information the Supreme Court has
roundly rejected prior restraints and
yes a non-disclosure order is a prior
restraint of speech potentially in
violation of the First Amendment for
reasons we don't really need to go into
it's not entirely clear whether a
non-disclosure order should be analyzed
under strict or intermediate scrutiny
but even assuming strict scrutiny
applies these kinds of non-disclosure
orders are generally constitutionally
sound so let's take a step back search
warrants under the stored communication
act happen all the time from both state
and federal law enforcement agencies I
do them frequently I don't just mean
Twitter warrants I mean warrants for
social media and other companies that
store vast amounts of digital
information warrants to Google for
emails and location information warrants
to meta for Facebook direct messages
these giant companies store immense
amounts of information on their users
often without the users really knowing
about it and law enforcement agencies of
all Stripes try to get that information
regularly what's notable about these
warrants is that they are two part
warrants sometimes called hybrid
warrants let's say you're investigating
a bank robbery if you got a search
warrant for an apartment the warrant
would spell out the place to be searched
the apartment and then the things to be
seized say Bank bags masks or guns if
you've got a search warrant for meta on
the other hand the two-part structure
comes into play but things to be seized
has two parts
the first part commands meta to turn
over certain records say all Facebook
communication for the week before and
after the bank robbery the second part
commands you the investigator to look
through those records produced by meta
for certain information meta may not
know what specific information you're
looking for they don't need to know
they're told hey turn over all these
communications and that's it you then as
the investigator are told look through
those Communications and find
Communications that talk about a bank
robbery or guns or masks whatever so
with all that in mind let's talk about
the special counsel's warrant for Donald
Trump's Twitter account judge Beryl
Howell signed the warrant on January 17
2023. the warrant was sealed meaning not
available to the public and the
non-disclosure order was signed at the
same time the warrant sought a lot of
information from Twitter for Trump's
account broadly in four categories first
subscriber information and that includes
devices used to log in or access the
account IP addresses that were used to
connect to the account and all these
between October 2020 and January 2021.
second Communications sent to or
received by Trump's account between
October 2020 and January 2021 but that
includes all tweets likes and retweets
as well as direct messages third
interactions between Trump's account and
other Twitter users between October 2020
and January 2021 and that includes all
users who followed unblocked blocked or
muted Trump's account or even who
favored it retweeted replied or
mentioned Trump's tweets finally the use
of Trump's account such as location
information and all searches performed
between October 2020 and January 2021.
to be clear that was the first part of
the warrant the part directed at Twitter
the second part telling the special
counsel's office what to look for in
those records has not been unsealed and
was never provided to Twitter
so we don't know exactly what the
special counsel is looking for in those
records although we do know generally it
has to do with the January 6th
investigation
and it's also worth mentioning that the
second category covering Trump's
Communications is really what caused
most of the commotion in this case the
warrant required Twitter to produce all
of those records within 10 days meaning
by January 27th the Government tried to
serve the warrant on Twitter the same
day that it was signed through Twitter's
legal portal website but apparently the
portal was down which I'm sure shocks
everyone after musk took over Twitter
it took two days for the page to be
restored and the government was finally
able to serve Twitter on January 19th on
January 25th two days before Twitter had
to turn over the records the government
contacted Twitter about the status of
the warrant
Twitter's senior director of legal
indicated that she wasn't aware of any
warrant but would make it a priority to
respond
senior director of legal also said
unsurprisingly that producing the
records in two days would be a tight
turnaround the next day January 26th the
day before the records were due Twitter
notified the government that it could
not comply with the warrant by the next
day because it just hadn't had enough
time fast forward to January 31st four
days after the deadline
Twitter indicated for the first time
that it would not comply with a warrant
without changes to the non-disclosure
order specifically Twitter wanted to
notify Trump about the warrant bold move
a little stupid and ultimately expensive
but bold now whether you're fighting the
doj or just your next door neighbor
you'll need a good lawyer but if you
want a great lawyer my firm the eagle
team can help if your loved one has
suffered an injury or death in the
family sexual harassment or were
involved in a car crash we can represent
you or help find you the right attorney
just click on the link in the
description for a free consultation with
my team because you don't just need a
legal team you need the eagle team link
below now back to scale out so on
February 2nd the government moved for an
order to show cause why Twitter should
not be held in contempt of court for
failing to comply with a warrant the
same day Twitter filed a motion to
vacate or modify the non-disclosure
order and stay compliance with the
warrant in other words Twitter wanted to
resolve the whole non-disclosure order
before it turned over any records at all
so what were Twitter's arguments about
why they shouldn't have to comply with
the non-disclosure order and the warrant
well basically Twitter argued that Trump
could potentially assert executive
privilege over some of what was sought
by the warrant and that Twitter had a
First Amendment right to inform Trump in
order for Trump to be able to assert
that privilege their arguments were
heard on February 7th in front of Judge
Howell in DC
judge Howell was not happy this was her
warrant after all she signed it which
makes it an order from her court and
it's worth noting that judge Howell
spent six years as a federal prosecutor
and as chief judge of the U.S District
Court for the District of Columbia she
supervised the Federal grand jury
involved in Robert Mueller's special
counsel investigation into Russian
interference in the 2016 election at the
February 7th hearing Twitter
acknowledged that it did not have
standing to raise Trump's executive
privilege claim over the records Twitter
possessed so instead it leaned heavily
on its own First Amendment right to
communicate with its customers
Twitter pointed to its policy that for
purposes of transparency and due process
Twitter's policy is to notify users EG
prior to disclosure of account
information of requests for their
Twitter account information including a
copy of the request unless we are
prohibited from doing so EG and order
under 18 USC section 2705 B that policy
is essential to its business model and
fostering trust with its user base now
one could plausibly ask okay so how many
times has Twitter actually ever filed a
motion challenging a non-disclosure
order given that thousands of warrants
they get every year and in fact that's
exactly what judge Howell asked on
February 7th Twitter's attorney could
not answer saying only that he in his
own experience had a couple of informal
conversations about non-disclosure
orders in the past
and after judge Howell gave Twitter the
opportunity to dig into its history and
look for past instances when it had in
fact filed challenges in court to
non-disclosure orders Twitter came back
with a whopping zero never before in its
nearly 17-year history as a company
and later judge Howell pushed even
harder has Twitter found any Court
decision in which a third-party company
like Twitter has successfully stayed
compliance with a search warrant pending
a First Amendment challenge to a
non-disclosure order
Twitter's lawyer know your honor not a
non-disclosure order so why this once
what's so special about this particular
case early on Judge Howell just straight
up went for the jugular and asked is it
because the CEO wants to Cozy up with
the former president and that's why
you're here and later is this to make
Donald Trump feel like he's a
particularly welcomed new renewed user
of Twitter here of course Twitter denied
that that obvious truth
Twitter said that in this case their
First Amendment right to notify its user
Trump was particularly important though
in a kind of roundabout way Twitter
noted that Nara the National Archives
and Records Administration requested
that Twitter turn over a lot of the data
it stored from Trump's account over the
duration of his presidency for the
purposes of archiving that data as
potential presidential records Twitter
suggested that the special counsel's
office should just go to Nara to get
what it's looking for the government
responded that one Nara doesn't have
everything that we want two that's not
how search warrants work you don't just
get to tell us to go look for evidence
somewhere else and three pursuant to the
regulations governing Nora Nara would
have to notify Trump about the request
for records and this is a covert
investigation and this was Twitter's aha
moment in one of their filings Twitter
stated that the government is attempting
an end run around the statutory
protections that Congress put in place
regarding presidential Communications
and that the statutory regime in place
never contemplated and does not account
for the circumstances at play here in
fact during the February 7th hearing
Twitter's lawyer told judge Howell this
is the first time in our knowledge that
private presidential Communications held
by a third party were being demanded by
the government through a warrant without
any notice to that former occupant we
were not aware of another time ever
where that has happened
judge Howell was not impressed by that
line of argument remember she supervised
the grand jury during the Mueller
investigation so she just had it ready
to go right in front of her and she
cited the fact that the Mueller
investigation obtained more than 230
orders for communications records under
the stored Communications act including
Trump's private messages to General Mike
Flynn so no sorry Twitter this is not
the first time this has happened and to
make matters worse it's not like judge
Howell's surprised Twitter's attorney
with the Mueller investigation factoid
Twitter itself cited the Mueller
investigation and its filings in order
to support its own position sadly
Twitter's attorney proceeded to dig
himself even deeper in response to judge
Howell's comments about the Mueller
investigation Twitter's attorney said my
understanding your honor is that the
Mueller investigators were in contact
with the White House counsel's office
about executive privilege concerns
this mirrors Twitter statements into
filing that the Mueller report contains
potentially privileged information but
that was not obtained without notice and
agreement
again judge Howell had to correct him
pointing out that the only time there
was notice to Trump about potential
executive privilege during the Mueller
investigation was when a witness was
being called in to testify in person to
the grand jury in other words where it
was not covert
as judge Howell said during the hearing
you need to read the Mueller report a
little bit more carefully
in fact judge Howell gave something of a
painful Master Class to Twitter's
attorney about how privilege actually
works in a criminal investigation she
pointed out that with every single
privilege with the sole exception of
congress's speech and debate privilege
there is no advance notice requirement
instead material obtained covertly by
the government that is potentially
privileged is typically subject to a
filter review protocol to identify that
and get judicial rulings on that that's
exactly how it works for say the
attorney-client privilege if a search
warrant is executed on an attorney's
office
any random attorney
a special filter team Combs through
those documents to identify potentially
privileged information and then there's
this whole process for the main
investigators and prosecutors to get
access to privileged information that
may be relevant to and needed in the
criminal investigation this goes back to
what Twitter knew and did not know judge
Howell started the February 7th hearing
by clarifying with the government
attorney that Twitter hadn't seen
anything more than the part of the
search warrant ordering them to produce
certain records the government attorney
responded that's correct your honor they
do not know about any filter protocol
that could or could not be attached to
the warrant that is a very Coy way of
saying yes there's definitely a filter
team
the February 7th hearing ended with
judge Howell holding Twitter in contempt
and leaving a fine schedule that doubled
every day five hundred thousand dollars
for the first day 100 000 for the second
day 200 000 for the third
Etc if Twitter were able to turn over
the records by 5 PM on February 7th
there would be no fun the contempt would
be purged
needless to say it took Twitter three
more days to get the records to the
government so judge Howell ordered a
total of 350 000 in fines for contempt
of court and the DC circuit upheld that
order in full now sure for a company
valued in the billions 350 000 is a drop
in the bucket but with recent inflation
it might just cover a smooth shave
actually shaving is really affordable
with today's sponsor Henson shaving now
you all know me as the beard wearing
legal eagle lawyer but I'll admit
there's nothing that'll get a jury more
suspicious of you than looking unkempt
and sloppy so keep in mind neck and
cheekbones clean is of utmost importance
or in the summer when I just shave it
all off which is where Henson comes in
for the longest time I've been using
those insanely expensive razors with the
Disposable five blade heads which work
but you go through the cartridges
quickly and they are insanely expensive
but this is where Henson with her al-13
single-bladed safety razor comes in they
are better for the environment and
better for your budget and everything
else and I can't tell any difference
between the Shea from Henson or the five
bladed ones the engineering that went in
into this thing is immense The Henson
al-13 razor is made using CNC machines
to Aerospace standards and the Razer is
actually really clever it's completely
idiot proof and they make sure that the
blade is seated 13 1 000 of an inch past
the shade plane every single time
because of the way it's engineered and
Henson blades only cost 10 cents so a
Year's worth of Shaving can only cost
three to five dollars with my promo code
you'll actually get 100 blades free
which could last for years and that's
why Hanson doesn't even try to sell you
a subscription Henson just makes a good
quality razor so if you decide that you
want to invest in a quality safety razor
that works and will be dramatically
cheaper than the other competitors then
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down in the description and
select which razor you'd like out of a
variety of different colors then use my
promo code legal eagle and you'll get a
hundred stainless steel double edge
replacement blades for free so again
click on the link below and use the
promo code legal eagle to get 100 blades
for free after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court